how to create more videos in less time
and we're actually going to be going
through 10 productivity tips with two
special guests and really there's going
to probably be about 63 different
tactical nuggets that you're going to
learn these are two of my favorite
people in the world they are part of our
video record Academy they've built their
own influence and doing so many cool
things on their own as well and I can't
wait for you to learn from them let's
get into these tips and I will kind of
pass it back and forth you both
submitted some powerful insights of just
what you've learned to get more done in
less time to be more productive and
we're going to start with Jacqueline and
tip number one here is use your passive
time productively and so
um you know Jacqueline you mentioned
some of the things you do whether from
commuting or how you're getting video
editing done break down some of the
things you do with kids with a busy
schedule to use your passive time
productively
not really when I started my channel I
was working most weeks 50 to 70 hours
and I commuted about 10 hours a week I
have two kids one of them is Special
Needs plus I have dogs and a husband and
I like to see them from time to time and
I worked a lot like a lot of hours
so I had to be really smart about what
time I did have
um so I tried to figure out every little
bit that I could use so from things like
you know I was part of the VRA program
so when was I going to sit down and
listen to all this training at home well
the answer was I wasn't so I was going
to listen to it while I drove to work I
might not be able to watch the video but
I could listen to it and the time that I
had
um I did little things like I kept a
small notebook that could go in my back
pocket I worked in a huge Factory so
like as I had ideas I would just like
write stuff down really quick
um and so they even like
um with my kids if you have little kids
you know that especially when they're
little little they watch the same
episode of whatever to get like for us
it was Bluey we watched probably a
hundred thousand times through so I
would edit while we would watch so I'd
still get cuddle time
um but I wouldn't have to listen to like
the same episode again so there was
still quality time but I used every
single minute I could to Think Through
what do I have to get done and how can I
fit that in the schedule that I do have
because I can't change the fact that I
work so much and commute
I love that and Ben I'd love to hear
from you especially taking us back to
you know you mentioned as this online
YouTube Media Company growing a business
thing grows we do hire editors
eventually or get help but take us back
to those early days when you were just
getting started and I loved Jacqueline
that you mentioned turning your car into
a college you know I know Ben you you
and I share that similar Vision yeah to
get down learning when you're busy you
are running a gym what are just some of
the things you did when you felt like
you didn't have enough time to get it
all done well number one I committed to
it there's a big difference between
being interested in something and being
committed I think it was Ken Blanchard
who said when you're interested in
something you do it when it's convenient
and then you give up when it gets tough
when you're committed you do whatever it
takes until you get results so big
difference between being interested and
being committed so I committed to it and
I knew that even though it might be slow
growth in the beginning there's no going
back like I threw my hat over the fence
I'm gonna have to go get that hat so
when there was slow growth I all knew
that it was all on the way not in the
way there was no giving up no quitting
and uh it's really impressive what
Jacqueline shared because she has a
family she has kids and she was juggling
all that I didn't have that same
situation I had my fiance and my dogs
but it's a different scenario but at
that time Sean I owned a CrossFit gym at
that time right so I was thinking about
all right I could serve my beautiful
CrossFit community and I could you know
trade time for money
um which was great and all but I decided
to actually leave my brick and mortar so
I could go online and actually serve
more people and that's where I made the
huge commitment I essentially like
jumped off the cliff and figured out how
to fly along the way and that's very
different than if I would have stayed
with my CrossFit gym or for you all
stayed with your job and I'm not saying
to quit your job but what I'm saying is
when you commit to something you find a
way and in the beginning that's what it
was for me so yes it was a lot of work
um you know when it's something that's
worth chasing I believe you got to put
in a lot of bandwidth and energy in the
beginning and then you get really smart
you start to delegate and for me when
that delegation started to happen I had
a big Challenge and I still have a big
challenge thinking that I do it the best
nobody could do it as good as me if I'm
going to hire an editor they're not
going to know all the little things that
I like and I have to spend all this
money and I had all this thinking
thinking but I knew that there was no
way I was going to do it by myself I
would be working from 6am to 12 a.m and
it would just be frustrating so I just
took that leap of faith and it was one
of the best decisions that I've made for
my business
I love it number two is use a calendar
and create checklist and so Jacqueline
um uh you mentioned and then we'll go to
Ben about planning and lists and so how
why has this been so important when it
comes to getting more done in less time
and uh time management yeah I think you
know if you're a busy mom or dad you
know that it can really quickly get very
overwhelming with all the different
stuff you have to do all the different
angles
um so I was really I spent a lot of time
making sure I thought through what do I
need to get done and I kind of thought
about it a little bit differently and
especially in the beginning as I was
figuring stuff out so instead of being
like
I have to get a video done every week I
started to try to think how can I do
work on a video four hours a week like
can I create four hours of work and then
what can I get done in the four hours
and I'll get as far as I can on my
checklist because when you have kids you
know and a job that eats up way too much
time which is what I had
um you just you only can do what you can
do and so having that mindset of like
let me go through my VRA checklist of
you know did I create my title did I do
my research right and then when am I
going to go and film and then when am I
going to edit but in the beginning I
didn't know how much time it was going
to take so it was more about okay I'm
gonna give myself two hours on Wednesday
night and I'll go down that list and
I'll see how far I can get and then you
know maybe I'll get it two hours on
Saturday I can sit and do and go far
down keep going down my list but the
good thing is is that instead of
becoming like oh well I didn't get a
video done this week it was like well I
use my time really effectively and I
kept moving through the list and then
over time I got faster and faster
and I got smarter about how I use time
but that's how I used calendars and
checklists was I thought more about time
and the activity and how far can I get
I love that you know I heard it said
that people who want to appear clever
rely on memory but people who want to
get things done make lists I don't know
about you but it always makes me nervous
when the waiter or the server at a
restaurant doesn't write things down I'm
always like I'm not impressed like I'm
like actually I would prefer especially
when you've got modifications and then
you know sure enough especially there's
eight people at the table they put their
hands behind their back and you're like
two orders end up getting messed up I'm
like listen if you can pull it off good
because then I'm impressed but it'd be
just a lot better to write it down it's
better to have a short pencil than a
long memory and so lists are really a
super power and uh Ben I want to hear
from you
um number two is use your calendar and
create checklists is a calendar
important for you to get everything done
first of all what you just shared was
brilliant Sean just dropping nuggets bro
I love learning from you uh yeah I live
on my calendar I really believe for
myself that blank space on my calendar
is the Devil's Playground and it really
starts with clearly defining my goals
and then matching my calendar to those
goals then I don't have time for things
that are not serving me another quote uh
Rob Robert Heinlein said in the absence
of clearly defined goals we become
strangely loyal to performing daily
trivia until ultimately we become
enslaved by it
so when I am clearly defining my goals
and I have that on my calendar daily
trivia does not own me I own my life I
own my action so I look at my I wake up
I look at my calendar and I'm like this
is what I'm doing today so when daily
trivia tries to seep in whether it's a
friend asking me to go out and do
something or whatever it is I don't have
time for that and that is my goal
matching to my calendar and I just live
on my calendar and it's not just my
business events that I put on my
calendar I put my workouts I put you
know my date nights with my fiance my
trips everything is on there and as long
as I follow that I know that I'm happier
I'm healthier I'm making a big
difference in my life so it's hugely
important for me because I have found
that when there is Blank Space daily
trivia tends to creep up and uh that's
not a happy way for me to live I don't
make an impact that way Sean so yes the
calendar I live by it and it's huge for
me
so powerful and so number one is use
your passive time productively number
two is use a calendar and create
checklists and then number three is turn
one video into four videos we have been
touching on uh batch producing but
Jacqueline break it down
um how batch producing has worked for
you and how you've ended up being able
to be so prolific with a busy schedule
yeah
world of
work every holiday every birthday you
get calls on weekends you come in in the
middle of the night for all the time so
your schedule gets thrown off so I
always had to create a buffer and do
batching and one of the things using the
VRA system that I started to do was I
started you know we talk about answering
specific questions
um and I found in the beginning I kind
of went a little bit more Broad and I
see a lot of other YouTubers do that in
the VRA community and outside of it and
what I started to do was really think
through like answering a specific
question and then how what are the other
questions people will have and how can I
break that into four or five videos so
I've done it over and over again I'm
constantly doing it um so one of the
things I did was I did a series of
videos on one plant and then I answered
every question about that plant but
every question from how to prune it how
to propagate it how to take care of it
how to identify it things to look for
when you're shopping every one of those
became their own video and what I found
is that not only is batching helping
with your time but when you're doing a
series of videos that are all on that
one topic it's really easy to film
because you don't have to keep in your
well at least for me I didn't have to
keep shifting gears because it was just
like well I'm just talking about this
one plant and I just had to pay
attention to my intros and my outros but
I could really really optimize what
filming time I had and editing time
because then I was able to pull all the
b-roll because it was all b-roll the
same plant and I could basically knock
out you know four or five videos maybe
filming them in like six hours and um
all the almost every one of those videos
ranks if not in the top five about half
of them ranked number one
such powerful tips and Ben
um you know you've been doing this 1 500
videos and so you've gone through
different seasons of live streaming and
videos and now you're at a different
level of scale and you're across
multiple platforms what are your
thoughts though on just getting more
done especially for the time starved
person yeah that's trying to keep an
upload schedule going when they have
minimal time how would you approach that
with minimal time to film edit and
upload during the week yeah like
Jacqueline shared I think it's important
to batch record and you can do that once
a month you could just block out four
hours five hours and knock out four or
five videos maybe even more and find a
flow that works for you so to give you
an example in the beginning right before
I launched my keto Camp YouTube channel
I had to figure out what's a good flow
for me that I believe would work meaning
it's sustainable and for me that was two
videos a week a video posted Monday a
video posted Friday now for you that
might be one video per week or one video
every other week whatever that flow is
we just I believe it's important to stay
consistent with that when I saw the
channel starting to really take off I
doubled that from two to four and then
it kind of took off from there but I in
the beginning I was just batch recording
uh once a month I would block out half a
day where I would you know do my
research ahead of time learning the 7R
system if you're in the VRA program
you're going to learn that and I wanted
to own my space like Jacqueline's owning
her space and she has amazing videos
like everybody in her space is following
her they find her on YouTube She's
ranking all these videos I wanted to do
the same thing for keto and then
eventually just in the entire Health
space so I started to think about what
are the most common questions I did my
searching now we have chat gbt and all
these cool things that help give us that
I'll give those data the data points to
us but I had a whole list that I
compiled and then I knew my stuff I knew
my information so I put that tripod on I
hit record and then I knocked it out
changed my t-shirt maybe put on a
different hat or took off the hat
knocked out a video now it's a little
bit different because I'm a little bit
more advanced and I have a lot of
studies that I'm referencing so uh
sometimes I'll use um
um what is it called uh Sean not a
projector but a teleprompter a
teleprompter sometimes yeah to cue me
and what I want to talk about but in the
beginning it was honestly a Apple notes
open with the bullet points and I just
hit record and back to record it and got
it done I love that yeah and Apple notes
is great I I like to use Google Docs
um because once I'm logged into Google
docs on my computer I also have the app
on my phone I can sit down with my phone
and actually just you know kind of use
your phone as a as a prompt for okay
this video and then walk through
everything and I love what you're
hearing from our guests too is that
there's different seasons to this and so
one of the biggest mistakes you can make
is if you copied exactly what Ben was
doing right now but you didn't have
Ben's team or Ben's situation or Ben's
even the financial situation it'd be the
wrong thing to emulate so it's like you
want to be applying the right strategies
in the right season and Jacqueline and
both and uh Ben are proof that it's
possible to do this in the side Hustle
season when you're figuring things out
when you're juggling lots of stuff so
many people VRA prove it is possible but
you got to see the price you got to see
the opportunities in your schedule you
gotta see that there's possibilities we
could look at our schedule as like it's
an impossible situation well then it
will be because if that's what you
believe about it but if you start saying
man if I start scheduling rethink about
this I can get this done and so that
brings us to number four which is keep
your video editing simple
at the start and so Jacqueline remind us
again so people were asking about video
editing what did you edit on and do you
edit on the same thing do you always
edit
and when you do what is your advice on
this number four tip keep your video
editing simple at the start so I
so in the beginning I and today still
today I shot completely on my iPhone and
because I was running into challenges
especially the first two and a half
years of first two years of my channel
of having time to sit at a laptop and do
work
um I edited on my phone with iMovie the
first two years I did everything on my
phone other than like the descriptions
so I kept it super super simple jump
cuts a little bit of b-roll a little bit
of music but no no fancy even today
barely any fanciness I would say I've
only got into any sort of fanciness now
but jump Cuts all day long simple cuts
um and honestly it you know look at
other niches or look at the niche you're
in you know some niches don't care I
would say in the gardening homesteading
world people don't they don't need fancy
stuff nor are they really that
interested in it so
um I kept it super super simple and
doing it on my phone
for two years completely
yeah this is inspiring because again
this is and you don't even have a
microphone correct no so you just have
your phone do you have like a tripod
I have a tripod yeah so you can set up a
tripod Are you standing sitting here
uh that one I'm sitting so you're
sitting down tripod up you start
delivering your info you put this in
iMovie we're about to see a little a
photo that you added to iMovie
illustrating what you're talking about
is very uh kind of you know basic things
as you walk through here but it's your
expertise it's the thing you've been
doing growing bananas this video has a
hundred and twelve thousand views shot
on an iPhone edited simply it's not
really about the production value it's
about the content value but I would even
challenge this is actually great
production value this is how good our
smartphones are now look sharp it's
1080p you know the phone picks it up and
people want the information and you're
able to deliver that Outdoors man it's
it's just so powerful what's possible
and sometimes we just kind of have to
bite the bullet and open up the software
one of the biggest things I see people
say all the time is like what's the
perfect software the one you actually
use like what software should I get
started with like the one that's already
on your phone like just start use
filmora or adobe or DaVinci or cap cut
or iMovie and I know that's overwhelming
but like literally just pick one because
you can always change kind of like Brian
Tracy says he's gonna eat the Frog
there's something about just starting
and then you can always make pivots
along the way
um but I'm curious uh can I give you a a
thing that I do that yeah really in that
vein so I know a lot of people when it
comes to thumbnails are using like canva
or photoshop I don't know you guys use
other stuff
um I only edit my my thumbnails in my
photo app or PowerPoint and the reason I
use PowerPoint is not because it's the
good software for it it's because in the
professional world I knew how to use
PowerPoint and when I would look at
canva I literally said like oh this
looks like you can do PowerPoint and so
to just save time I would just like
throw the picture on a slide and then
put whatever word text I wanted on there
and then just take a screenshot like
literally the latest thumbnail on my
channel is done in Powerpoint
that's beautiful and one
million 913
509 views on your channel you've reached
millions of people at this point in
terms of people that have seen your
content been exposed to your content and
you're just getting started and you're
already experiencing so much success I
just want to encourage you what's the
best software tube 1K challenge to use
the one you have access to the one
that's free the one that's already on
your computer the one you already know
how to use and so um so inspiring and
keeping video editing simple at the
start Ben have you did you edit your
videos at any point yeah in the
beginning I was and what software did
you use Final Cut Pro is what I used
how'd you learn it
YouTube
how to use Final Cut Pro on YouTube
that's what I searched um I love that
Jacqueline just is like eliminating all
the excuses out there that you have to
have all these fancy equipment and it's
just it's really the content showing up
and delivering it and being consistent I
I know that even for myself I think oh I
gotta you know get better production get
this fancy camera and I think that's
more of like a selfish thing that I feel
good that I get this cool camera but
really just show up and and hit record
the fact that you have an iPhone or
whatever it is a smartphone that's good
enough right there get started right
there and then you just get better and
you grow or you just stay with the
iPhone that's fantastic too I mean look
at Jacqueline she's crushing it with her
phone
um so yeah I use Final Cut Final Cut Pro
in the beginning took a lot of time to
learn it took a lot of time editing I
would spend hours
um four or five hours on a 15 minute
video I did use storyblocks.com as uh
for b-roll I paid like a membership I
think like 40 bucks a month where I
could just like download certain b-roll
that I could put in my video and I would
use Final Cut Pro to put it in there and
then eventually I I got an editor I know
I have two editors that help me with the
YouTube channel
yeah it's amazing and so
um version
one is better than
version none we learned yesterday from
rad getting it out there and you can
always up uh update your software your
cameras your gear along the way this
brings us to number five and uh this is
protect your mindset and your energy and
Ben you had a lot of stuff to share here
and I think that this is kind of like
the UN thought about productivity tip
that sometimes if we think about a
calendar we think about lists we think
about uh we think we're robots I think
sometimes too but you talked about how
you how you spend your morning how you
spend your night you talked about the
subconscious mind and I know you're into
uh so much science-backed insights and
Human Performance and getting more uh
you know productivity out of ourselves
and so what are some things that you do
to protect your mindset and your energy
so that you can put out your best work
to serve your mission your purpose your
YouTube channel your community and the
difference you want to make in the world
this is this is the most important tip
right here so Shawna I might go a little
long so you just feel free to like reel
me in if you need to but
I believe 95 of your success in life
whether it's Health YouTube
relationships Finance is mindset um and
five percent of strategy I call it the
mental six-pack and there is a certain
time during the day that we really want
to protect our time and I'm going to
explain that before I do I want to share
how powerful the mind is with two short
stories that I'm going to keep them
short John so we've all heard of the
placebo effect I think you all have
heard about that let me know in the chat
box if you have but the placebo effect
started in uh World War II when the
Americans were getting bombed they're
the soldiers that were getting bombed
they were going to the medical tent
there was a doctor named Dr Henry
Beecher who was attending these soldiers
they were coming in with bullet wounds
arms blown off it was a nasty situation
and of course what they did for these
soldiers is give them morphine because
it would prevent them from going into
shock and stabilize them they could
transfer them to the hospital they would
survive but what happened is that they
ran out of morphine and one of the
nurses she didn't know what to do they
didn't have any morphine these soldiers
were going into the shock so she put
saline solution which is just salt water
in the needles and she gave it to Dr
Beecher and told Dr Beecher she was
giving him morphine so he had the belief
they had he had morphine in that needle
he told the soldier I'm giving you
morphine you're gonna feel better in a
matter of seconds so he transferred his
belief and what happened they survived
from salt water and then Harvard studied
what happened there in World War II and
that's where the placebo effect came
from and then there's the nocebo effect
where your mind could work against you
meaning if you believe you could grow
your YouTube channel and you really
developed that belief really strong and
I'll talk about the morning time for
that you're right but if you believe you
can't do this and you're not smart
enough or you can't afford the equipment
or whatever it is you're also right
because there's the nocebo effect and
there was a football game in Los Angeles
California an entire Stadium filled with
people and they're watching a football
game and two people opposite ends of the
stadium start getting really sick they
start projectile vomiting and they rush
to the clinic in the stadium stadium and
the doctor is attending to these two
people he wanted to know why they're so
sick why are they throwing up and the
only thing they had in common was that
they both drank soda from the soda
machine so his thought was there's
something wrong with the soda machine he
immediately went on the public address
system and told the entire Stadium
please do not drink from the soda
machine and we believe there are two
people here that are getting really sick
and throwing up from the soda machines
and what happened after he said that an
entire Stadium of people started
throwing up all over the place
ambulances were taking them back and
forth and they determined two hours
later there was nothing wrong with the
soda machine when they got the news they
stopped being sick that is the power of
the mind and in the morning and right
before bed or is when the subconscious
mind is most impressionable so the tip
is this protect your morning the first
90 minutes of my day is protected goals
gratitude Tony Robbins priming red light
therapy I mean mine's a little extensive
but it might be 10 minutes for you find
a way to not just hop on your phone
right away and have a time in the
morning where you're reading a book or
doing something to set up your day right
and I would also recommend doing the
same thing right before bed as you do
that you'll develop that belief you'll
reprogram that subconscious mind you'll
change those neural Pathways and it's
going to mean everything for you not
just for you to but you're in your
entire life
those stories are so powerful and um
I've learned a lot of this stuff from
you I mean what's actually funny is got
my red light panels over here these are
the kind of thing click in your
affiliate links which is this is kind of
a even if you think full circle as you
start getting into these things you know
tying it back into I follow someone like
Ben because I want to reach high
performance and I learn about products
from him there's unspeakable products uh
Ben that you've taught me about that
I've got down in my refrigerator
um and uh people probably are like what
does he mean by that but I mean I'll
just put it out there like I've learned
about suppositories that's right out of
the way and again NAD plus and all kinds
of stuff a little TMI probably for
everybody watching here but like the
punch line is uh back on track is is man
protect your mindset and your energy and
one some of the stuff you said no phones
no social no distraction affirmations
getting gratitude and then you also
before we go to the next tip here
um you may mentioned every year you do
an audit can you can you talk about this
one
yeah so I I do an audit on my
environment because your environment
determines your thoughts your thoughts
determine your actions and your actions
determine your results so if you want to
change your thinking and your actions it
starts with your environment so I do an
audit on the people that are close to me
friends family
um business partners Etc and I put them
into two different buckets I learned
this from Dean graziosi he calls them
Chargers or drainers so drainers would
be obviously people who drain you people
who you have a conversation with and
you're drained they're gossiping they're
telling you why do you want to have a
YouTube channel that's silly that's
stupid it's too late for YouTube YouTube
has been around for too long and you
feel drained they go on one side of the
piece of paper and then the other side
are people like Sean people like think
media people like Jacqueline Chargers
people who support me cheer me on uh
they inspire me they go on the other
side of the paper and I'm very
intentional with spending more time with
the Chargers in less time with the
drainer so I recommend you do that audit
I do it once every year
so powerful and of course you know we
love our family and you have different
friends and Thanksgiving with whoever
and Christmas but yeah the way you put
is you spend less time with the drainers
and more time with the Chargers yeah one
of the things we've learned at think
media
um and one of the the powers probably
out of everything inside of VRA fam one
of the most powerful things is getting
around a community of people that are
maybe thinking different than some of
the people around you right now as well
as the Facebook group like just imagine
keeping this kind of conversation going
the VRA show monthly like with how
important psychology is and your mindset
is to actually having success on YouTube
that's why just a course is really not
enough information alone is not enough
it's about getting support and getting
surrounded with the community so that
you get your mindset right and so that's
definitely one of my favorite tips and
uh that brings us to uh let me recap and
we're gonna go to number six here so
number one use your passive time
productively
number two use your calendar and create
checklists number three turn one video
into four videos use batch producing
number four keep your video editing
simple at the start number five protect
your mindset and your energy and number
six stay flexible uh I just saw Victoria
talking about in the in the back end you
might be saying first 90 minutes of the
day wait till you have kids what happens
and I'm kind of in that tension point
right now because with the two and a
half year old with a seven month old man
before those I read a book called The
Miracle morning and my Miracle morning
was just a whole Zen experience
uninterrupted now you never know if you
get a surprise a little one wakes up but
I've actually still found that if I'm
disciplined uh I can get up early enough
or that you just have to get creative
and you got to stay flexible you know if
we become too rigid like I have to shoot
this Saturday but life comes up stuff
comes up and so Jacqueline
um you said when we were talking about
the pre-planning of all this make a plan
but stay flexible can you break that
down
absolutely absolutely and actually I
want to say something about number five
because one of my favorite phrases that
kept me going when I was having hard
days from VRA was I will until because
that that mindset motivation is I could
go on and on about it the in the
factories that I worked in was PepsiCo
and what I did for 10 years was culture
change so specifically working to change
people's mindsets and processes so
that's all in my jam but when it comes
to flexibility you know it's it's really
about and this is why I loved VRA
because it gives you the steps it gives
you the process it gives you what you
should be working on so when you map out
you use your calendar you make your
checklist right Focus what I did is I
focused more on what I could control and
what I can control is my behaviors and
my actions what I can't always control
is the outcomes so I might not be able
to if I keep working on my checklist I
might not have finished the video as
fast as I thought I was going to but I
control that for two hours I dedicated
myself I worked on my checklist right
but it even comes down to like I've got
kids and it's great that I say I'm gonna
set aside a couple hours to go film and
then they want you know someone's
melting down someone scrape their knee
someone whatever but even to the point
of like they want they they are aware of
YouTube and they want to be in the shot
and so I just try to roll with it it's
like okay well I can't get them out of
shot so I guess we're going to be in
shot the video is not about them but
like Ken I literally had one um my
oldest son is Special Needs I could not
get him to stop talking so I literally
was just like okay you're gonna say
number one and then I would say seeds or
something I don't know whatever the
topic was and then I would get them to
say number two and he was so excited and
about 10-15 minutes of him getting to
say number three and I try to get him to
say some of the other words he you know
like squirrel and he moved on and dad
was able to come in and help with that
um but sometimes you got to kind of roll
with it like maybe you're just gonna
have to cut it short because the kid's
melting down it just happens
um and so I always try to figure out
ways where one of my little ones super
attached so I had a video supposed to go
show how to plant strawberries this
literally was like a couple months ago
and instead the video was him and I
planting strawberries and it didn't
necessarily go to plan but you know a
lot of the people who I feel like
in the history like I would have been
like oh it's not the way I wanted it to
be but so many people commented about
how cute he was and they were so
supportive of seeing like a little kid
learning the skills of gardening so
because I wasn't reacting like it was a
problem in the video I was just reacting
like Hey we're doing this and I'm
rolling with it the audience right my
community reacted at a similar way which
was accepting and loving it so it became
a really nice thing in the video instead
of it being a problem so try to think
about when you have challenges sometimes
they can be just make them into a
different solution than what you
expected
yeah and and I mean Life Is Life and and
what I've also I've learned about
Seasons especially now as our whole
season has changed we've had different
seasons of of health challenges some
people here were talking about dealing
with chronic illness Ben knows that I've
uh been dealing with kind of a carpal
tunnel repetitive stress injury and that
I was talking about this I think on VIP
a question came up about how I've dealt
because I've talked about chronic pain
and chronic illness and and who you're
around you could probably see hanging
out with Ben for a little bit he starts
getting into a different mindset you
start realizing like I feel better just
talking to him and then there starts
being that practical those tips and uh
all of those things can help us but one
of the terms that I love is Grace based
productivity yeah Grace based
productivity where we have Grace on
ourselves where we hold ourselves to a
high level of accountability hold
ourselves to a high level of
productivity but at the same time give
ourselves Grace like it's okay if maybe
one day doesn't go good or we need to
take a break what should you do if
you're tired
rest like it's okay to take a day off
think about where we're going to be in
the next five years rather than just in
the next five minutes the best thing we
can sometimes do I saw someone say is
breathe take a break be flexible let
today maybe go and we can pick it back
up tomorrow but Jacqueline you may have
hit this but I want to just call it back
to you again you said that in the
beginning you had time blocks on your
to-do list and you had you were you had
like certain targets like maybe doing 10
videos in 12 weeks but you found that
sometimes
um that you didn't always hit that did
you just talk about that or that was no
not quite so in the beginning write that
down yeah so in the very very beginning
because I think one of the hardest
things when you're getting started with
YouTube is
um for most of us it's not the career
we're in so I didn't like how long is it
gonna take to film how long is it going
to take to do research how long is it
going to take to script I had no idea
what to block out time with
um so in the beginning you know I I
targeted doing a video week but I was
definitely giving myself a lot of Grace
of like well I just don't know how much
time it's going to take so in the
beginning I would do things like I'm
gonna get home a little bit early but
before the kids get home so I've got one
hour to do whatever it is I can do and
as I go I'll get better and so I think
having that Target but like Sean was
saying like give yourself Grace because
honestly I think sometimes in the
beginning we're so excited about growing
on YouTube
um we we just want to make it all happen
right now and that is the fastest way to
burn out and so by allowing myself to be
like I'm gonna hit a video a week but I
might not have time because I like I
still got to pay the bills and be with
my family
um so I'm gonna just try to do as much
as I can during the time I can do and I
was really proud of myself I got 10
videos done in 12 weeks and there were
weeks I missed but I felt good about it
because the time I did block out I was
productive and I kept moving forward and
so I really focused on am I in the time
I'm giving myself doing the things I can
do and that I can control because I
can't control that I don't know how to
edit yet and I don't know how it works
on iMovie yet on my phone so I gotta
figure that out or you know I don't I
didn't know that like my neighbor was
gonna because I'm gardening channel
right they're gonna mow their lawn and
now here's a lawnmower during that hour
I blocked out that it is what it is like
I'm not gonna there's nothing I could
change about it so I really gave myself
a lot of Grace and like I I think there
used to be like a in the old days right
like it was very tortoise versus the
hair like just know that like in the
long run it's gonna work out because I'm
Gonna Keep keep picking at this
um but it might not all be the way I
think it's going to in the next couple
weeks or the next few months and so I'm
just focusing on it it's so funny you
bring that up it really is kind of like
Murphy's law that during the exact hour
you're filming is the hour that your
neighbor is Landscaping with power tools
or even today right before the first
session I went down and my son was like
juice and so I started making juice and
I was mixing up this electrolyte base
zero sugar juice I mixed a little bit of
sugary cranberry juice in there I didn't
screw the top on there boom red juice
all over the kitchen during the 10
minute countdown this morning on session
number four and I was like oh my gosh
that's the kind of stuff specs your
mindset I'm like honey she already is
taking the kids today we're like
throwing the towels down and man you
need some Grace based productivity
because you know a lot of times when
you're trying to be productive and you
know one of the phrases we say I think
media is blessed are the flexible those
who Bend and don't break man you got to
be flexible and Ben really quick before
the next tip or or anything that you
have to share with us what are some
things you've learned whether when you
get a setback bad news as an
entrepreneur you know what it is to get
punched in the face and punched in the
gut maybe physically but I mean
metaphorically uh you know where yeah
you you have trouble draw challenges a
hard week a hard year a hard month what
have you learned about staying flexible
yeah great white I'm all about Flex uh
keto Flex is my book so yes I'm all
about being flexible with keto included
yeah I think well I I really believe
this that the most important thing is to
love what you're teaching you know
Jacqueline loves gardening she loves
Florida and um it's like when things
come up it's like okay this is just part
of it it's all on the way not in the way
you know Sean you love teaching YouTube
you love teaching mindset and develop
developing your business it's like find
something that lights you up I love
teaching health and keto is a big part
of that so when uh there's obstacles you
know a funny story because you're
talking about the juice thing every
Wednesday at 12 p.m eastern time I go
live on my YouTube channel and I've been
super consistent with that in four years
I probably have missed maybe seven
Wednesdays in four years and that's
because I was traveling and recently I
cracked the windows open here in my
apartment because I like to get a good
you know Breeze coming in here I don't
know if there's a beehive by my building
but I'm in the middle of a live stream
and there are like 30 bees going into my
room here and on my and my fiance is
allergic to be
it was a b attack and I'm like I gotta
go I gotta I gotta stop this live stream
right and everybody's laughing and like
you know it's all just part of it right
but yeah you know to answer your
question when when obstacles occur when
setbacks occur my mindset I teach this
to my students it is not about the
setback it is about the get back
setbacks or setups for something great
as long as you're so committed and you
love what you do there's learning
opportunities in all of that the problem
is that so many people don't love what
they're doing they're probably teaching
a topic because they think that's what's
going to be popular or that's what's
going to do well there's not going to be
longevity in that there's not going to
be stamina in that but when you love
what you teach there is longevity
there's stamina you produce energy
whenever you need it so those
um stop signs become speed bumps when
you love what you teach so that would be
my advice like you're going to be
flexible when you love what you're
teaching I can't get over this B attack
like this the whole thing
like one of the different stories the
trials of content creators the one time
when I got attacked by bees during a
live stream
um so stay flexible that's number six uh
stay flexible uh which brings us to
number seven and I love this one get
help get help and we're gonna start with
Jacqueline you know sometimes what we
think about when we think about get help
um what we don't mean is is is get help
like see a therapist although you should
do that too I think because we all need
help uh you know the Beatles reminded us
help like I need somebody we all need a
little bit of help but help could just
mean can we enroll
a family member you know in the vision
can we enroll our partner and be clearly
uh more clear about what we're asking
hey honey could you watch the kids on
Saturday morning
um can we uh get assistance and get help
from ways that doesn't have to be hiring
somebody although that is important too
and Ben can have a lot of wisdom to
share there so Jacqueline what is your
thoughts on um this idea of get help
yeah I my husband also named Dan
um when we started doing videos I had a
lot we had conversation well he watched
some of the videos too like the I think
you had a mastermind back then we
literally watched it together and you
know he we had very like Frank
conversations about like what it was
gonna take to try doing a YouTube
channel what kind of time commitments it
potentially was going to take and you
know what I love is that even though I'm
the face of the channel my husband is a
hundred 150 behind the mission of the
channel he is my super secret sniper in
the background that's just like he is so
proud and so passionate about what we're
doing to get people
um and it would be very hard to do what
I'm doing if he wasn't 100 on board
um because he does you know when I go to
film like he'll have both kids and
that's not always easy especially with
um we've gone through some challenges
with with dysregulated behaviors and
stuff really bad ones and um but he
helped with that even my mom and dad
like they would pick up my kiddos and
then like keep them maybe like an hour
later and I would try to get home like a
half hour earlier and that would be my
film time because I like run home and I
would literally like get out of the car
throw my stuff down do a little
something so I didn't look like I'm in a
sweaty Factory all day and then walk
outside and just be like okay I'm
talking
um so my parents have also been super
helpful with just like maybe watching
the kids for a couple hours
um and stuff like that and then I have
friends who are just supportive and like
rate comments every now and then
um so that's always helpful too it
doesn't have to be like hiring people
it's it really can just be small things
like hey can you walk can you distract
the kid can you go play tag with the
kids for like 30 minutes so I can finish
figuring out this title and thumbnail
like it literally is like we will to the
minutes I'll be like can you I just I
think I need 15 Ben's like 15 or 10 and
I'm like okay Ted I'll try to make it
work
no this is so powerful and I know that
people do have questions about hiring
and and we're going to drop uh some tips
on that in just a second but I actually
want to challenge you right now you're
watching this whether live or on the
replay to start journaling and number
one to to start writing down some names
of just the people in your world the
people in your world that number one you
may need to enroll in the vision have
you discussed building a side business
your future budgeting for this thinking
through this who do you need to talk to
um to maybe ask for help sometimes just
a list of people and maybe it's the
people you haven't thought of oh my
sister-in-law oh or my cousin somebody
who maybe is wanting to earn some extra
money you've got a nephew or somebody's
14. he could you know you start thinking
yeah I could probably they could babysit
on Saturday mornings start just writing
down and brainstorming a list of people
in your world and then start writing
down and brainstorming a list of tasks
sometimes the
thing that could be is hiring a video
editor or sometimes the more practical
thing again could be like getting
somebody involved to watch the kids so
you could edit the video
um and like Jacqueline says or you edit
the video on your phone while uh you're
watching Bluey I was going to say blippi
because uh my son's super into blippi
and Mika right now he calls him blappy
you know what's funny when it comes to
help too is my son um it goes help like
when it needs help with anything he goes
help and I feel like we could be a
little bit more like like Sean Bradley
my two and a half year old and ask for
more help and when we start to enroll
people around us in our vision
um a lot of more momentum can happen but
Ben and one other I forgot to even
mention is
um all my direct neighbors are super
support of the channel they know I have
a channel and so they will
um probably after the six months they
would now when they see me go out there
their film they'll be like oh I was
going to pressure wash my card you want
me to hold off for two hours you know
like they're literally all like all my
immediate neighbors will they will
actually go out of their way to like
stop mowing or stop blowing or stop
cutting wood or whatever they are doing
that day or my one neighbor who's next
door he will be playing music on the
radio as loud as get out you know it's
all copyright the music and I'm like hey
Shane do you mind like turning it down
I'm gonna film and he's like yeah he has
a project going on he's got contractors
he spent a bunch of time talking his
contractors so that they knew not to
drive onto like what would be my yard
because he knew those were all native
plants and that I would want to like
make sure they were protected and he
made and like he checked on it every day
and then he let me know he's like hey I
just want to let you know like I talked
a lot with those contractors they know
not to step on any of it like super
super sweet they're all so sweet and
supportive and protective of the channel
and they don't like so it can even be
stuff like that wow no it's so powerful
and and so I want to okay so write down
a list of names just brainstorming and
then write down just also a list of
tasks and then write down some
conversations that you know you need to
have because when it becomes written it
becomes real you're all you're holding
yourself more accountable and and also
remember that it is the person's right
to say no and you're not going to get
hurt offended you're you're simply you
you're they might say no but they also
might say yes so if they say yeah no I
don't know if uh I could commit to you
know to Saturdays a month of helping out
you're not mad like you got nothing to
lose you're just maybe get and then
maybe by simply telling them your vision
we need to articulate our vision
articulate what we're doing once you
start to articulate and clarify what
some of your goals what your vision is
you'd be surprised maybe the person says
no for 45 days but they go hey are you
still doing that YouTube thing they're
like yeah they go actually my Saturday's
opened up I would love to actually help
out you know that could be your aunt you
know mother in law or something and
you're not offended if they say no the
question is what happens if people start
saying yes and you'd be surprised that
there could be a lot more opportunity in
your world when you are bold and
courageous write down a list of people
write down some various tasks and maybe
some things you could invite help for
and then write down some conversations
that you want to have like I know I want
to talk to this person about that and
the framing and opening of the
conversation is listen no pressure and
obviously you know I don't even expect
you to do this but would you consider
and uh you'd be surprised what could
potentially happen there but Ben I'm
curious because you did hire and
committed to hiring your first
editor but did you have a budget for it
at the time or what was your situation
then and what did you learn
well first of all I'm impressed with
Jacqueline's neighbors I mean that's
she's got some great neighbors wow yeah
um I didn't have a budget for it I
I looked at how much time I was spending
uh editing videos and then I looked at
how much I would spend on on Fiverr is
what I used to to pay an editor and I
felt like my time was worth more um my
what I was paying what I would have paid
the editor made sense because I felt
like my time was worth that my worth the
money I was going to spend there I think
I'm making sense there so I would
recommend figuring out what you think
your time is worth an hour right and if
let's say you feel like that's a hundred
dollars an hour is what you value your
time then I think anything underneath
that should be delegated I didn't have a
budget for it and I figured out ways to
get creative and get that budget now I'm
not going to give Financial advice here
but I tend to bet on myself so I'll tend
I tend to get like small business loans
like stripe PayPal the cool thing about
those loans is that you pay them back
with your income they take a certain
percentage so I did that I bet on myself
and you know I I won essentially because
I paid that back got the money back and
that one editor then turned into an
assistant that I hired and then now I
have two assistants now I have three
health coaches that you know work for me
in my keto Camp Academy but it really
started with that one person I didn't
have a budget for it I'm not Dave Ramsey
I didn't do it that way but I better
myself and I got really strategic with
um with capital and I do think it's very
important to eventually bring on a team
or that's one person or five people
because I do believe if you want to go
fast go alone but if you want to go far
make big impact then you got to go with
the team you teach that all the time
Sean we are in on number eight which is
pace yourself and so Jacqueline you you
shared some stuff and you touched on
this a little bit so we could probably
get to nine pretty quick but speak to
the idea of pacing yourself when it
comes to uh
doing this YouTube
so I'm a all-in kind of person so I
wanted to be like get it all done get to
you know I don't know what number
subscriber in my head I thought I would
get to in the beginning but
um I really have learned that pacing
yourself because you're going to go
through times where stuff goes really
well you're going to go through times
where for some reason the video just
doesn't hit right and if you just keep
focusing on that long game right that
that tortoise be that tortoise you will
win in the end it might take longer than
you think but you just really gotta pace
yourself because otherwise you hear
about so many creators burnout and you
know I feel like if I could be I'm so
glad you guys asked me to be here
because I feel like I could be a good
example of someone who works a lot at
hours it would have been very easy for
me to burn out and it was through pacing
myself that allowed me to be successful
I didn't come out doing a million videos
a week I just did a video week or what I
could do and then you know it grew the
first 100 subscribers is the worst I
will say that it took a long time to get
there for me you may go faster
um but I had a pace myself I really
really had to and it's worked out and it
that's the other thing right it's like
the numbers are it's more about the
people and when you focus on the people
and the individuals you're gonna win
you'll win because you don't have to
have a million subscribers to make a
full-time income you don't
so so true and one of my I'm so glad you
mentioned Tortoise and the hair I
actually have uh this this website's
called Ugg Monk and I got this um
graphic where it's kind of in Gold Leaf
at our Vegas location and it says slow
and steady wins and you could see a
little turtle there at the end of the
Winds and so this was him developing the
art but that Tortoise and the hair story
is so powerful because
um if you sprint leave all your energy
up at front it's even pacing I've run a
few half marathons you got a pace in the
half marathon you you don't just leave
it all out there you might not even
finish because you burn out too soon but
it's so much more about the long-term
Journey than it is just about the next
week or the next year I love both of
your Visions because your mission is a
lot bigger than let's just make some
videos and make some money of course you
need money for the mission but both of
you are really Purpose Driven people
that's our biggest you know passion is
to help purpose-driven entrepreneurs and
content creators and so you're not just
about the next year you're about Legacy
you're about like the future really
quick give us a little bit of that
purpose that drives you both of your
purposes inspire me at the highest
levels but Ben like what is what is your
purpose fueling your YouTube channel
well I mean there's so many people who
are unhealthy uh unnecessarily the stats
out there are
devastating cancer heart disease Etc
and I know that a lot of these diseases
are preventable I lost my dad through
the complications of diabetes in 2014
and I know that what I teach all over
the world now would have saved my Dad's
life if I would have applied what I
teach he would be alive today to see all
the cool things that I'm up to but I
also get that I was given that mountain
so I could show the world the mountain
can be moved so my mission is to help
the world help one billion people
actually that's the goal Inspire one
billion people and help them understand
your body was built to be self-healing
you have everything you need inside your
body to be self-healing we just got to
remove the interference and you are a
masterpiece because you are a piece of
the master so that inspires me because
I've seen so many I've helped so many
people get off their meds reverse their
diabetes stage four cancer it's just
amazing what I've seen and it lights me
up because there's so many people out
there who are
sick and unhealthy and they could get
their life back with what I teach so I
always keep that the Forefront and helps
me serve the purpose and the mission
gets my attention off of myself and how
cool I look how cool I sound which did
not serve me in the beginning and it
puts my energy into the mission
band so powerful Erica says it makes her
cry and you know it's giving me chills
as you talk it brings us back too and I
want because this is session five and we
do have two more tips but because this
is session five
um bringing us all the way back to
session number one where we talked about
why is it that you want to start YouTube
and reasons come first results come
second what are the reasons driving you
I think you can feel the power and the
energy behind what Ben is sharing but
Jacqueline you have a whole Vision that
I'm like okay I meet you you're in VRA
I'm like you love gardening great but
then I start to hear from you you're
like no I like want to change the
ecosystem of Florida like I want to like
shape literally the atmosphere so
breakdown what's like your vision for
your channel yeah so
born in Florida but I was lived here
pretty much my entire life and you know
Florida is one of the fastest growing
States there's so many people coming
from all around the country and all
around the world but the challenge is is
that they're they they bring with them a
lot of the ideas of how nature should
look in Florida and that's not actually
what Florida looks like
um so really what the vision of the
channel was was to help people start to
learn what Florida is from a ecosystem
Wildlife standpoint and integrate it
into their own homes because okay this
will be like the negative part usually a
very happy and focused but like you know
we've lost over 50 percent of our our
bird population we've lost about 90
percent of our native bee population we
have many many species that have only
almost gone extinct and are exclusively
live in the state of Florida
um and they've we've had ones that we
thought actually work stink but because
of the work of people and what they do
in their Gardens and out in our
conservation and restoration areas you
know we we have the ability to change
and we are making changes but with so
many new people they just don't even
know what they don't know because we're
so unique down here and I love how
unique we are we have we're one of the
best states to watch Birds we're one of
the best states for butterflies 17 of
the world species only exist in Florida
so there's a lot of really cool stuff
going on down here and I I don't want us
to lose it just because we have so many
new people who just really don't know
and a lot of times when people talk
conservation and saving Wildlife it's
just like donate money and it'll go to
some park somewhere else but so many of
us can have make the difference make the
change from our own yards
um you know 80 of the land east of the
Mississippi is privately owned and it's
one of the reasons why we're losing a
lot of wildlife is because of plant
choices of what people are putting in
their Gardens so I focus a lot on native
plants and getting people excited about
putting native plants in their Garden
because they can really start helping
our whole entire uh food web and you
know they don't have to just focus on
the big ones like the Florida panther
but like they can be helping things like
the atala butterfly which we actually
thought went extinct in like the 1930s
but it's completely made a turnaround
because people started including native
plants in their Gardens so I'm really
passionate about that so powerful and
and for those worrying or wondering we
still have point nine and ten coming up
a little bit of a rabbit Trail here but
actually kind of our bonus tip of this
session because we are on session five
is I do want to call you back to your
Journal writing down your reasons
writing down your why and maybe type
tapping into deeper levels of
inspiration and drop it in the comments
as well reason being is when I see
Jaclyn's success and Ben's success it is
evidence to me that yes they've invested
in their learning and they've persevered
and they've paced themselves but once
you start going deeper you dig beneath
the surface you're like wow there's like
a fire it's those reasons it's this
mission that they're on and it's it's
real like this is a big key we are
obsessed with you winning on YouTube and
your success but we also know that
that's going to probably be unlikely if
you don't tap into those deeper driving
force purpose having a strong why having
a why that makes you cry something that
gets you out of bed in the morning
something that'll keep you going and I
want to encourage you you might be like
I'm not sure what it is it's there we
may just need to be able to unearth it a
little bit and even increase it like
raise necessity on it a little bit
because that'll be a huge key to success
on YouTube so we're going to hit 9 and
10 in just a second but Ben said he had
one other thing to share on this so Ben
uh take it away yeah just uh real quick
there's a a book that I read every
morning called radical wisdom from
Reggie Campbell I don't know if you have
that book Sean if you don't I'm going to
send it to you but he takes excerpts
from the Bible and it relates it to real
life and the other day just the other
day the the title of it was are you
driven or are you cult
and it resonated with me so much and
it's it's exactly what we're talking
about here there's a big difference
between being driven and actually
feeling like you're called to provide a
service and have this Mission when
you're driven you know you just go go go
you could burn yourself out you get
negative comments you stop but when
you're called like you have energy you
have um you're in a flow State negative
comments just deflect off of you like
water off a duck and I feel called I
know Sean feels cold Jacqueline feels
cold and I want all of you to feel
called not just driven so I just want to
make that point there and I believe
there is a big difference between being
driven and actually being called
man dropping some fire we're going deep
on the session 505 number nine though
let's go to number nine uh invest in
programs coaches and mentors Ben this
came from the notes that you submitted
you said that uh this is something that
you've done it's been a pattern for you
and so what power have you seen in this
and then we'll take it to you jack uh
this is a huge tip right here Tony
Robbins always says he could take
Decades of learning and turn that into
days when you invest in a coach a mentor
or a program a book I'm a student you
can see all the books behind me and it's
funny when I was in school high school
college I did not read books unless it
was a textbook to you know graduate a
class but now all I do is read and I
study three hours every day for the last
14 or 15 years three hours every day
whether it's physical books podcasts or
audio books that is one format of
investing into a mentor but then there's
another level to that because
information alone Sean said this a
little while ago information alone will
not change your life we are drowning in
information and starving for Wiz wisdom
and truth it's the application of the
right information with Elite coaching
over a period of time that will change
your life if it's just the information
every librarian would be a
multi-millionaire and a celebrity and
that is not the case so I invest a huge
percentage of my monthly of my yearly
income on courses I've invested into VRA
I've done I went to grow with video live
last year I I've invested in your
masterminds I'm investing into coaches
all the time and it takes me from a
level uh five to a level ten and a level
10 to level 15 and it sometimes when you
invest in a coach and a mentor you the
accountability part is so huge to have
somebody hold you accountable it is Bob
Proctor used to say accountability is
your success insurance policy it takes
your goals to your results and it sticks
them together so having accountability
is huge and then also sometimes I know
for myself I tend to have self-limiting
beliefs and sometimes I don't believe I
could hit a certain goal I have desires
but I don't have the belief but a coach
a mentor Sean somebody think media they
could have the belief in you and you
could borrow their belief until you
actually adopt that belief for yourself
and that right there is a huge value in
coaches and mentors and yeah Sean in
think media you guys have been huge for
believing in me and seeing that belief
until I developed it so I think this is
a huge tip right here
I appreciate your kind words and
Jacqueline before we get to number 10
what has been your experience whether
investing in in VRA or just seeking
outside of yourself to continue to learn
and level up
yeah no I I'm lifelong uh and I would
definitely always recommend finding a
coat for whatever you're going to do in
your life finding coaches and mentors
because we learn personally through
trial and error and so when you're doing
things that you've never done before you
don't I mean that's what I was saying
about gardening you don't know what you
don't even know so you don't even know
the questions you should be asking so
you need to get around people who know
what things you should be doing to get
you started and that can look like a lot
of different things from the stuff you
find for free on YouTube to I I love VRA
I think it's just broken down so well
and helping you work through what you
need to do I'm sure you could figure it
all out on your own if you spend enough
time but if you want to just like and
then the community around it because I
had a mentor throughout my professional
career and he always talked about
Johari's Window which is you know the
window has four panes there's what you
know what people see and what you know
about yourself and that they can see
what what you know but there are things
that you don't know about yourself that
others can tell you that they see and
you need people who are outside of you
so that's why I like the VRA community
so much because you can post your
thumbnails and get feedback you can post
your video and get feedback you know
because you may have those blind spots
that you just you you think you're doing
okay but you just can't figure out why
is it not working and it just takes that
other coach or peer or Mentor or that
Community like VRA to just watch and be
like Oh yeah this very thing and like
everyone else will tell you oh it's so
obvious but you have blinders on you
can't see it
um so having that plus having someone
guide you down the path you know you can
make it through a forest if you know
enough if you don't know I mean you're
gonna spend a lot of time wandering
around so why not have someone who puts
the road map out for you
um so I've invested in VRA when Sean had
the Inner Circle I was part of inner
circle I've had a coach for helping us
write our book which will be coming out
in the next couple months and I even
have a business coach to help us kind of
figure out like what are the right
products and offerings for the community
so that we can continue to grow the
business so I I'm a big fan of investing
yeah I love that and as we land the
plane and we've gone through our uh 10
tips number 10 is enjoy the journey and
I know for me that sometimes
um this is all super fun but sometimes
you wake up and you're like oh man I
gotta shoot a video today or um you know
one of my favorite authors is Stephen
pressfield who wrote books like do the
work
um or the the war of Art and he talks
about the resistance and for anybody
that wants to do creative work and even
that has a calling and you feel that
mission you still wake up and think
maybe I'm gonna do it tomorrow and not
today the resistance that's like oh
you're not ready to shoot the video yet
oh what what you know people aren't
going to take you seriously uh you know
you know all this self-doubt the voices
in our head the negative self-talk the
resistance and so sometimes even though
this can be fun work
it is easy to lose joy in the process
and I love what you said Jacqueline this
was inspired all these tips were just
synthesized from everything you
submitted but you inspired this because
you said learn to enjoy the process
Jacqueline can you talk a little bit
about that and then Ben's gonna land the
plane on this tip oh yeah because I I
think you know we we want to find the
joy and the results and the results
always come or they don't come in the
way that you think they should come and
so you know I think I've talked a lot
about like focus on the things that you
can control which is your behaviors and
so you know find the joy in editing that
you're gonna spend a lot of time editing
editing takes more time I feel than most
of the other steps um but I really like
doing the editing because when you know
I most my career in the factory I love
doing what I did in the factory but I
didn't have any way to do anything
creative so I liked how in the editing
like you know especially as I kind of
continue my journey like what music am I
going to use in there and like what
b-roll shots and like how can I kind of
tell a story and make kind of a
narrative to get a message across that
isn't necessarily an obvious message and
kind of take people through things so I
really enjoy kind of uh I do Vlog Style
videos at times where I really focus
more on feelings I mean we might
gathered I'm interested in people's
feelings but like the feeling of like
it's really hot and miserable it's the
middle of summer you still gotta go out
there and garden how do I convey that
feeling so that my fellow Floridians are
like yeah me too it's really hot it
sucks right now and then they feel kind
of seen and like how do I make them feel
motivated in a video when you know we
kind of go through a second wave of
restarting our Gardens in the fall and
it's like how do I get them re-motivated
you know and and just acknowledging
finding the fun things that you like in
the process I like figuring out how to
convey those stories Messages Plus the
information about native plants you can
always tell my thumbnails about native
plants because I look super excited
because I'm like yay I get to talk about
butterflies and and native plants again
so find the parts that you really like
and lean into those and that aren't
about the results that are about the
process because those will be the things
because sometimes I don't want to edit a
video and I'm like you know what I'm
just gonna I'm gonna do like a montage
of flowers for like two minutes in this
video because I just want to and I'll
just throw it in there and some people
don't like it and a bunch of people do
like it